2005's fantastic four may not be a film
marvel fans or superhero fans in general
want to remember but it exists whether
they like it or not
2007's fantastic four rise of the silver
surfer
didn't do much to improve upon its
predecessor and 2015's reboot fantastic
four
unfortunately followed that same
downward trend with another fantastic
four reboot on the way
fans can only hope that another film
starring marvel's first family
doesn't go the way of the negative zone
part of what could make that happen is
having the actors and director work well
together
which was not the case for rise of the
silver surfer indeed jessica alba who
played susan storm aka the invisible
woman
didn't exactly get along with director
tim story alba had such an unsavory time
filming rise of the silver surfer
that one particularly difficult scene
nearly made her say goodbye to acting
for good
for a bit of context alba hasn't always
been on the best terms with
screenwriters
being quoted in elle magazines december
2010 issue as saying
good actors never use the script unless
it's amazing writing
all the good actors i've worked with
they all say whatever they want to say
this caught the attention of many
writers in hollywood most notably
charlie's angel scribe john augus
who wrote a blog post in an attempt to
explain why albert's comments were
hurtful
and quote setting dangerous expectations
according to alba the quote was taken
out of context
as she explained during a press event
for 2010's little [ __ ]
it's not that alba thinks scripts don't
matter it's that she personally
feels she doesn't know how to not be
tied to a script and to improvise when
needed which she apparently considers
the mark of a good actor
alba went on to say basically i was
saying that i didn't have the courage
and didn't really understand how to
bring my own thing to the table
and i would never veer away from the
script ever no matter what
this confession from albert ties into
her experience on rise of the silver
surfer
she reportedly had a number of
experiences where she was told to read
the words on the page in the exact way
they were written
that made her lose confidence in herself
and her acting abilities
it's nice to be wanted sometimes reid
drawing one of the emotional climaxes in
rise of the silver surfer
alba's character sue is crying as she
dies in her husband read richard's arms
but the sequence seen on the big screen
and the way it was originally shots are
completely different
alba acted out the crying scene perhaps
the way it was written in the script
but it wasn't what the director wanted
according to alba story told her to
quote be prettier
during the scene albert explained to l
magazine
i remember when i was dying in silver
surfer the director was like it looks
too real
it looks too painful can you be prettier
when you cry
cry pretty jessica just make it flat we
can cgi the tears in
the director critiquing an actor's work
and asking for some degree of adjustment
is one thing
but to take advantage of her looks
rather than her emotional range
and say animators will digitally modify
her performance
it's hard to imagine what that felt like
at the time the experience made albert
question not only her worth as an actor
but also her worth as a human being as
she told elle
it all got me thinking am i not good
enough are my instincts and my emotions
not good enough
do people hate them so much that they
don't want me to be a person
from there alba began to feel
differently about the acting profession
as a whole
i just said okay i don't care about this
business anymore
thankfully she didn't end up quitting
acting explaining to el that motherhood
gave her a thicker skin
and helped her become more confident in
the face of criticism
since the release of rise of the silver
surfer in june 2007
alba married cash warren whom she met in
2004 while filming fantastic four became
a mother of three
and has been in numerous films and tv
shows some of her most notable roles
include kam wexler in good luck chuck
nancy callahan in simcity a dame to kill
four and
victoria knox in barely lethal and from
2019 to 2020
albert held a main role as nancy mckenna
in the bad boys spin-off series
la's finest fantastic four rise of the
silver surfer may have pushed albert and
nearly quit acting
but we're glad she didn't let the tough
time dull her shine
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite superhero movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one